Dr. Zakir, what is the meaning of Zakat
al-Fitr? And what are its rulings in
Islamic Sharia?
As far as the meaning of the word Zakat
al-Fitr is concerned, Zakat, as it is
discussed earlier, means
to purify.
It means to clean. And Fitr means the
breaking of the fast. So, Zakat al-Fitr
means purifying charity
for the breaking of the fast.
And it is an amount of food given to the
very poor Muslims
or the needy Muslims.
It is a fixed amount of food given to
the very poor or the needy Muslims. And
as far as its ruling is concerned,
it is obligatory on the Muslims. It's
fard.
And it's mentioned in Sahih Bukhari,
volume number two, in the book of Zakat,
hadith number 1503, the beloved Prophet
Muhammad said that he has enjoined
on every Muslim to give one sa' of dates
or barley
as Zakat al-Fitr
on every Muslim,
slave or free,
male or female, young or old. So, it's
fard
for every Muslim,
male or female, young or old, slave or
free.
And it's also mentioned in the hadith of
Sunan Abu Dawud, volume number two,
in the book of Zakat,
hadith number
1618.
The beloved Prophet Muhammad made Zakat
obligatory for every Muslim.
There are
very few number of scholars, very small
number, hardly any,
who say that it was fard before, but
it's no longer fard today, based on the
hadith
of
Sunan an-Nasa'i,
book of Zakat,
hadith number 2509, where Qays ibn Sa'd
ibn Ubadah,
he says
that Prophet Muhammad made Zakat al-Fitr
obligatory
before
Zakat was made obligatory.
And after Zakat was made obligatory, he
did not command us, nor forbid us, to
give Zakat al-Fitr.
But we had practiced it. So, based on
this hadith, a very small number of
scholars say that after Zakat became
obligatory on the Muslims, Zakat al-Fitr
is optional, it's not fard. But this
hadith, nowhere does it say that it's
not fard.
It's only the saying of one of the
Sahabah
that Zakat al-Fitr was made fard before
Zakat. He doesn't say that after that it
was prohibited.
The Prophet didn't repeat the
commandment. And whenever any act of
worship
had been made fard, and another act of
worship comes which may be more in
quantity, that does not mean the
previous act of worship has to be
stopped, unless there is evidence.
So, based on this, most of the scholars
agree that Zakat al-Fitr is fard for
everyone. And the reason for both is
different, inshallah we shall discuss
later. So, the right ruling is that it
is fard on every Muslim.